foreign
delighted to have with us here today my
old friend Professor Faye family
feifei is a professor of computer
science at Stanford University and also
co-director of Hai the human centered AI
Institute and previously she also was
responsible for AI at Google Cloud as a
chief scientist for the division it's
great to have you here thank you Andrew
very happy to be here so I guess
actually how long have we known each
other I've lost track
definitely more than a decade I mean
I've known your work right before we
even met and I came to Stanford
2009 but we started talking 2007 so
15 years and actually still have very
clear memories of how stressful it was
when collectively you know a bunch of us
me Chris Manning a bunch of us are
trying to figure out how to recruit you
to come to Sanchez it was a hard I just
needed to sort out my students and life
but uh it's hard to resist Stanford
it wasn't really great having as a
friendly colleague here for yeah me too
it's big
[Music]
it's been very lucky to be the
generation
seeing ai's great progress okay so there
was something about your background I
always found inspiring which is you know
today people are entering AI from all
walks of life and
um sometimes people still wonder oh I
majored in something or other is AI a
right path for me so I thought one of
the most interesting positive background
was that you actually started out not
studying computer science or AI but you
started studying physics and then had
this path to becoming you know one of
the most globally recognizable AI
scientists and so how did that how did
you make that switch from physics to AI
right well that's a great question
Andrew especially both of was passionate
about young people's future and their
they come into the world of AI the truth
is if I could enter AI back then more
than 20 years ago today anybody can
enter AI because AI has become such a
prevalent and
globally impactful technology but myself
maybe I was an accident so I have always
been a physics kid or stem kids I'm sure
you were too but physics was my passion
all the way through you know middle
school high school college so I went to
Princeton and majored in physics and one
thing physics has taught me till today
is really the passion for asking big
questions the the passion for seeking
North Stars and I was really having fun
as a physics student at Princeton and
one thing I did was reading up
stories and just writings of great
physicists of the 20th century I just
hear about what they think about you
know the world especially people like
Albert Einstein Roger Penrose you know
Irene Schrodinger and it was really
funny to notice that many of the
writings towards the later half of the
career of these great physicists were
not about just the atomic world or the
the physical world but ponderings about
equally audacious questions like life
like intelligence like human conditions
you know Schrodinger wrote this book
what is life and Roger Penrose wrote
this book Empress new
new mind right and that really got me
very curious about the topic of
intelligence so so I one thing led to
another during college time I did intern
at a couple of Neuroscience labs and an
especially Vision related and I was like
wow this is just as audacious a question
to ask as the beginning of the universe
or what is matter made of and that got
me to switch from undergraduate degree
in physics to graduate degree in AI even
though I don't know about you during our
time AI was a dirty word it was AI
winter so it was more machine learning
and computer vision and computational
Neuroscience yeah I know honestly I
think when when I was in undergrad I was
too busy writing code I just you know
managed to Lively ignore the AI winter
and just kept on coding yeah well I was
too busy solving pde equations
and so actually do you have an audacious
question now yes my audacious question
is still you know images I think since
Alan Turing Humanity has not fully
understand what is the fundamental
Computing principles behind intelligence
I you know we we today we use the words
AI we use the word AGI but at the end of
the day
I still dream of a set of simple
equations or simple principles that can
Define the the process of intelligence
whether it's animal intelligence or
machine intelligence and this is similar
to physics for example many people have
drawn the analogy of flying right are we
replicating birds flying or are we
building airplane and a lot of people
ask the question of the relationship
between Ai and brain and to me whether
we're building
um
a bird or replicating a bird or building
an airplane at the end of the day
aerodynamics and physics that govern the
the the the process of flying and I do
believe one day we'll discover that yeah
I sometimes think about this you know
one learning album hypothesis good a lot
of intelligence maybe not often a lot of
it be explained by one or a very simple
machine learning principles and it feels
like we're still so from cracking
that nut but in the weekends when I have
spare time when I think about learning
algorithms and where they could go this
is one of the things I still you know
I'm excited about right just thinking
about I totally agree I still feel like
we are pre-newtonian if we're doing
physics analogy before Newton there has
been great physics great physicists a
lot of phenomenology a lot of studies of
how the the the astral bodies move and
all that but it was Newton who started
to write the very simple laws and I
think we are still going through that
very exciting coming of age of AI is a
basic science and uh we're pre-newton in
my opinion it's really nice to hear you
talk about out despite machine learning
and AI having come so far it still feels
like there are a lot more unanswered
questions a lot more work to be done by
maybe some of the people joining the
field today then work that's already
been done absolutely I mean let's let's
calculate it's only what 60 years about
it's a very nascent field modern his
physics and chemistry and biology are
all hundreds of years right so I think
it is very it is very exciting to be
entering the the field of science of
intelligence and and studying AI today
yeah actually that's cool I think I
remember chatting with the late um
professor John McCarthy who had coined
the term artificial intelligence and boy
the field has changed since when you
know he conceived of it at the workshop
and came up the term AI but maybe
another 10 years from now you know maybe
someone watching this will come with a
new set of ideas and then
we'll be saying boy AI show is different
than what you know you and I thought it
would be that's an exciting future to
build towards yeah I'm sure Newton would
have not dreamed of Einstein so you know
our evolution of science sometimes takes
strides sometimes takes a while and I
think we're absolutely in a in an
exciting phase of AI right now
you know it's interesting hearing you
paint this Grand Vision for AI
going back a little bit there was one
other piece of your background that I
found you know
inspiring which is um when you're just
getting started I've heard you speak
about how
you know you're a physics student but
not only that you also you're also
running a laundromat to pay for school
and so just tell tell me more about tell
us more about that well yeah
um so I I came to this country to
America to New Jersey actually when I
was 15 and one thing great about being
in New Jersey is it was close to
Princeton so I I often just take a
weekend trip with my parents and to
admire the the place where Einstein
spend most of his career in the latter
half of his life but uh you know with
typical immigrant life and it was tough
and by the time I entered Princeton my
parents didn't speak English and
one thing led to another it turns out
running a dry cleaner might be the best
option for my family especially for me
to lead that business because it's a
weekend business
if it's a weekday business it would be
hard for me to be a student and it's
actually believe it or not running a dry
cleaning shop is very Machine Heavy
which is good for a stem stem student
like me
so we decided to open a dry cleaner shop
in a small town in New Jersey called
Parsippany New Jersey it turned out we
were physically not too far from Bell
labs and there were lots of early
convolutional neural network
research was happening but I had no idea
and actually a summer intern at the
agency
with Rob Shapiro with Michael Kearns was
my mentor and Rob schipperary inventor
of boosting great algorithms so you're
coding AI I was trying to clean clothes
only much later in my life that I
started running
it was something
somebody did that for the entire
undergrad and most of my grad school and
I hire my parents
and yeah yeah no that's really inspiring
I think it you know I I know you've been
brilliant to doing exciting work all
your life and I think the the story of
you know running a laundromat to
globally prominent computer scientists I
hope that that inspires some people
watching this that no matter where you
are there's plenty exactly everyone yeah
don't even know this um my high school
job was a office admin
um
and so to this day I remember doing a
lot of filter copying and and the
exciting part was using the shredder
that was the Glamorous one but I was
doing so much fellow coffee in high
school I thought boy if only I could
build a robot to do this fill the coffee
maybe I could do something else did you
succeed
and then um you know when people think
about you and your the work you've done
one of the huge successes everyone
thinks about is imagenet right where
um Hub established early Benchmark for
computer vision it was really completely
instrumental to the modern rise of deep
learning and computer vision
um one thing I bet not many people know
about is how you actually got started on
imagenet so it tells the origin story of
image that yeah well Andrew that's a
that's question because
of that as labeling a ton of images but
where we began was really going after a
North star brings back my physics
background so when I entered grad school
when did you enter grad school which
year uh 97. okay I was three years later
that year 2000 and that was a very
exciting period because I was in the
computer vision and computational
Neuroscience lab of Pietro perona and
Christoph at Caltech and leading up to
that there has been first of all two
things was very exciting one is that the
world of AI at this point at that point
wasn't called AI computer vision or
natural language processing has found
its lingua de Franco it's machine
learning statistical modeling as a new
tool has emerged right I mean it's been
around and I remember when the idea of
applying machine learning to computer
vision that was like a country virtual
thing right and I was the first
generation of graduate students who were
embracing all the base net or the
inference algorithms and and all that
and that was one exciting happening a
second exciting happening that most
people don't know and don't appreciate
is that a couple of decades probably
more than two two or three decades of
incredible cognitive science and
cognitive Neuroscience work in the field
of vision in the world of vision human
Vision that has really established a
couple of really critical North Star
problems just understanding human visual
processing and human intelligence and
one of them is the recognition of
understanding of natural objects and
natural things because a lot of the
psychology and cognitive science work is
pointing to us that is an innately
optimized whatever that word is
functionality and the ability of human
intelligence is more
robust
faster and more nuanced than we had
thought we even find neural correlates
brain areas devoted to faces or places
or
body parts you know so so these two
things led to my PhD study of using
machine learning methods to work on
real-world object recognition
but it became very painful very quickly
that we are coming banging against one
of the most
um continue to be the most important
challenge in Ai and machine learning is
the lack of generalizable
generalizability you know you can design
a beautiful model or you want if you're
overfitting that model yeah I remember
when it used to be possible to publish a
computer vision paper you know showing
your works on one image exactly yeah
it's just
the models are not very expressive and
uh and we lack the data and we also as a
field was betting on making the
variables very expressive Rich by like
hand engineer features remember you know
every variable carrying a ton of
semantic meaning but with hand engineer
features so
and then towards the end of my PhD my
advisor Pietro and I start to look at
each other and say well boy we need more
data we if we believe in this North Star
problem of object recognition and we
look back at the tools we have you know
mathematically speaking we're
overfitting every model we're
encountering we need to take a fresh
look at this so one thing led to another
he he and I decided we'll just do a at
that point we think it was a large-scale
data project called Caltech 101 and I
remember the data set I wrote papers
using you know your Caltech on the one
you did you and your early graduate
student benefit a lot of researchers
yeah Caltech 101 data you know that was
me and my mom labeling images
oh and a couple of undergrads but that
was it was the early days of Internet so
suddenly the availability of data was a
new thing you suddenly I remember Pietro
still have this super expensive digital
camera
um I think it was Canon or something
like six thousand dollars walking around
Caltech taking pictures but we are the
the the internet generation I go to
Google image search I start to see these
thousands and tens of thousands of
images and I tell Pietro let's just
download of course it's all that easy to
download so one thing led to another we
built this Caltech one-on-one data set
of 101 object categories and about
I would say 30 to 50 30
000 pictures I think it's really
interesting that um you know even though
everyone's heard of image net today
um even you kind of took a couple
iterations where you did Caltech 101 and
that was a success lots of people used
it because the even the early learnings
from building Caltech 101 they gave you
the basis to build what turned out to be
even an even bigger success right except
that
that by the time we start I became a
assistant professor
we started to look at the problem I
realized it's way bigger than we think
just mathematically speaking Caltech 101
was not sufficient to to power the the
algorithms we decided to emit to do
image that and that that was the time
people start to think were were to or
doing too much right it's uh it's just
too crazy the idea of downloading the
entire internet of images and mapping
out all the English nuns was a little
bit uh I start to get a lot of pushback
I remember at one of the cvpr conference
when I presented the early idea of image
that a couple of researchers publicly
questioned and said if you cannot
recognize one category of object let's
say the chair you're sitting in how do
you imagine or what's the use of a data
set of 22 000 classes and 50 million
images yeah but but in the end you know
that giant data set unlocked a lot of
value of uh you know countless number of
researchers around the world so that so
that was well I I think it was the
combination of betting on the right
North Star problem
and the data that drives it
so it was a fun process yeah and you
know to me one of the
um when I think about that story it it
seems like one of those examples where
you know sometimes people feel like they
should only work on projects the huge
thing at the first outset but
I feel like for people working machine
learning if your first project is a bit
smaller it's totally fine have a good
win use the learnings to build up to
even bigger things and then sometimes
you get a you know every schnet size win
all of it yeah well but in the meantime
I think it's also important to be driven
by an audacious goal though you know you
can size your problem or size your
project as local milestones and and so
on along this journey but I also look at
some of our current students they're so
peer pressured by this current
a climate of publishing non-stop it
becomes more incremental papers to just
get into a publication for the sake of
it and I I personally always push my
students to ask the question what is the
North Star that's driving you yeah
that's true yeah you're right you know
for myself when I do research over the
years I've always
pretty much done what I'm excited about
where I want to you know try to push the
view forward doesn't it don't listen to
people I have to listen to people let
them shape your opinion but in the end I
think the best research is let the world
shape their opinion but in the end Drive
things forward using their own opinions
totally agree yeah it's your own inner
fire right
so as a research program developed
you've wound up taking your let's say
foundations in computer vision and
Neuroscience and applying it to all
sorts of topics including your very
visibly Healthcare located Neuroscience
applications
um would love to hear a bit more about
that yeah happy to I I think the
evolution of my research in computer
vision also kind of
kind of follows the evolution of visual
intelligence in animals and there are
two topics that truly excites me one is
what is a truly impactful application
area that would help human lives and
that's why Healthcare work the other one
is what is Vision at the end of the day
about and that brings me to the um the
the trying to close the loop between
perception and robotic learning so on
the healthcare side
you know one thing Andrew there was a
number that shocked me about 10 years
ago when I met my long-term collaborator
Dr Arne milstein at Stanford Medical
School and that number is about a
quarter of a million Americans die of
medical errors every year
I had never imagined A number being that
high due to Medical errors there are
many many reasons but we can rest assure
most of the reasons are not intentional
these are eras of unintended you know
mistakes and and so on for example it
does a mind-boggling number it is it's
maybe about 40 000 deaths a year from
Automotive accidents which is completely
tragic and this is even vastly great I
was going to say that I'm glad you
brought it up just one example one
number within that mind-boggling number
is the number of Hospital acquired
infection resulted fatality is more than
95 000. that is more than that's 2.5
times than the death of uh car accidents
and in this particular case hospital car
infection is a result of many things but
by enlarged lack of good hand hygiene
practice
so if you look at who
there has been a lot of protocols about
clinicians hand hygiene practice but in
real Healthcare delivery
um the the when things get busy and when
the process is tedious and when there is
a lack of feedback system you still make
a lot of mistakes another medical
tragic medical fact is that more than 70
billion dollars every year are spent in
in four resulted injuries and fatalities
and most of this happened to elderlies
at home but also in the hospital rooms
and these are huge issues and when Arnie
and I got together back in 2012 it was
the height of self-driving car
Silicon Valley and then we look at the
technology of smart sensing cameras
lidars
Radars whatever smart sensors machine
learning algorithm and holistic
understanding of a complex environment
with high stakes for human lives
I was looking at all that for
self-driving car and realized
in healthcare delivery
we have the same situation much of the
process the human behavior process of
healthcare is in the dark
and if we could have Smart sensors be it
in patient rooms or or senior homes to
help our clinicians and patients to stay
safer that would be amazing so Arne and
I embarked on this what we call ambient
intelligence research agenda but one
thing I learned which probably will lead
to our other topics
is as soon as you're applying AI to real
human conditions there's a lot of human
issues in addition to machine learning
issues for example privacy and I
remember reading some of your papers on
with army and found it really
interesting how you could build and
deploy systems there were you know
relatively privacy preserving yeah well
thank you well the first
iteration of that Technologies we use
cameras that do not capture RGB
information and you've used a lot of
that in self-driving car the depth
cameras for example and there you you
you preserve a lot of privacy uh Privacy
Information just by not seeing the faces
and the identity of the people but
what's really interesting over the past
decade is the changes of technology is
actually giving us a bigger tool set for
privacy
preserved Computing in this condition
for example
on device inference you know as the
chips getting more and more powerful if
you don't have to transmit any data
through the network and to the central
server you help people better Federated
learning we know it's still early stage
but that's another potential tool for
privacy preserve Computing and then
differential privacy and also encryption
Technologies so we're starting to see
that human demand you know privacy and
other issues is driving actually a new
wave of machine learning technology in
in ambient intelligence in healthcare
yeah that's great yeah I've been
encouraged to see the you know real
practical applications of differential
privacy that are actually real
Federation learning as you said pray the
PR's live in the head of the reality but
I think we'll get there but it's
interesting how consumers in the last
several years have fortunately gotten
much more knowledgeable about privacy
and are increasingly so important I
think the public is also making us to be
better scientists see
and and I think and I think ultimately
you know people understand AI holds
everyone including us but hosts everyone
accountable totally doing the right
thing yeah yeah
and you know and on that note one of the
really interesting pieces of work you've
been doing has been um leading several
efforts to help educate legislators so I
hope governments especially U.S
government
um work toward better laws and better
regulation especially as it relates to
AI
um that sounds a very important and and
I suspect some days of the week I would
get so much frustrating work but would
love to hear more about that
yeah so I think first of all I have to
credit many many people so about uh four
years ago and I was actually finishing
my sabbatical from Google time I was
very privileged to work with so many
businesses you know Enterprise
developers just just a large number and
variety of vertical industries of
realizing ai's human impact and that was
when many faculty leaders at Stanford
and also just our president Provost
former president and former Provost all
get together I realized there is a role
historical role that Stanford needs to
play in the advances of AI we were part
of the par part of the birthplace of AI
you know a lot of work our previous
generation have done a lot of work
you've done and some of our work I've
done let to AI today's AI what is our
historical opportunity and
responsibility with that we believe that
the next generation of AI Education and
Research and policy needs to be humans
entered and
having established the human Center AI
Institute what we call Hai one of the
work that really took me outside of my
comfort zone were adding expertise is
really a
deeper engagement with policy thinkers
and makers because you know we're here
in Silicon Valley and there is a culture
in Silicon Valley as we just keep making
things and the law will catch up by
itself but AI is impacting human lives
and some sometimes negatively so rapidly
that it is not good for any of us if we
the experts are not at the table with
the policy thinkers and makers to really
try to make this technology better for
the people I mean we're talking about
fairness we're talking about privacy we
also are talking about the brain drain
of AI to Industry and the
concentration of data and compute in a
small number of of technology companies
all this are really part of the changes
of our time some are really exciting
changes somehow have profound impact
that we don't we cannot necessarily
predict yet so one of the policy work
that Stanford H AI has very proudly
engaged in is we were the one of the
leading universities that lobbied a bill
called the national AI research Cloud
task force bill it changed the name from
research Cloud to research resource so
now the Bill's acronym is Nair National
AI research resource and this bill is
calling for a task force to put together
a roadmap for America's public sector
especially Higher Education and Research
sector to um increase their access to
resource for AI compute and AI data and
it really is aimed to rejuvenate
America's
ecosystem in AI Innovation and research
and I'm on the 12 person task force
for under Biden and administration for
this bill and we hope that's a piece of
policy that it's not a regulatory policy
it's more an incentive policy to build
and rejuvenate ecosystems I'm glad that
you're doing this to help shape U.S
policy and this type of making sure
enough resources are allocated to you
know ensure healthy development AI it
feels like this is something that um
every country needs at this point yeah
so you know just from the things that
you are doing by yourself not to speak
of the things that the global AI
Community is doing there's just so much
going on in AI right now certainly
option is so much excitement
um I found it for someone getting
started in machine learning for the
first time sometimes there's so much
going on they can almost feel a little
bit overwhelming totally what advice do
you have for someone getting started in
machine learning great question Andrew
I'm sure you have great advice you're
one of the world known advocate for AI
machine learning education so
um I do get this question a lot as well
and one thing you're totally right is AI
really today feels different from our
time
that's true when we were
starting in English
I love that exactly exactly part of this
when we got started the entrance to Ai
and machine learning was relatively
narrow you almost have to start from
computer science and go right you know
as a physics major I still had to wedge
myself into the computer science track
or electrical engineering track to to
get to AI but today I actually think
that there is meaning aspect of AI that
that creates entry points for people
from all walks of life on the technical
side I think it's obvious that there's
just a incredible plethora of resources
out there on the internet from Coursera
to you know YouTube to tick tock to
GitHub to the to there's just so much
that students worldwide can learn about
Ai and machine learning compared to the
time we began learning machine learning
and and also any campuses we're not
talking about just college campuses
we're talking about high school campuses
even sometimes earlier we're starting to
see more available
classes and resources so I think there
is I do encourage those of the young
people with the technical interest and
resource and opportunity to embrace
these resources because it's it's a lot
of fun but having said that for those of
you who are not coming from a technical
angle who still are passionate about AI
whether it's the downstream application
or the the creativity it engenders or
the policy and social angle or important
social problems whether it's digital
economics or the governance governance
or you know history ethics political
sciences
there I do invite you to to join us
because there is a lot of work to be
done there's a lot of a lot of unknown
questions for example my colleague at
are questioning are trying to find
answers on how do you define our economy
in the digital age
what does it mean when robots software
are participating in the workflow more
and more how do you measure our economy
that that's not a AI coding question
that is a AI impact question we're
looking at the incredible advances of
generative Ai and there will be more
what does that mean for Creative
creativity
and to the creators from music to Art to
writing I think you know there is a lot
of concerns and I think it's rightfully
so but in the meantime
it takes people together to figure this
out and and also to use this new tool so
I think
in short I just think it's a it's a very
exciting time and anybody with any walks
of life as long as you are passionate
about this there's a role to play
I think that's really exciting is how
about economics think about you know my
conversations with um Professor Eric
brinhausen right studies impact of AI on
the economy but from from what you're
saying and I agree it seems like no
matter what your current interests are
AI is such a general purpose technology
that the combination of your current
interest and AI is often promising
I find that even for Learners that may
not yet have a specific interest you
know if you find your way into AI start
learning things often the interest will
evolve and then you can start to craft
your own path and given where AI is
today there's still so much room and so
much need for a lot more people to craft
their own paths to do this exciting work
that I think the world still needs a lot
more of totally agree yeah so one piece
of work that you did I thought was very
cool was starting a program initially
called Sailors and then later AI for all
which was really reaching out to you
know high school and even younger
students to try to give them more
opportunities in AI including people of
all walks of life I'd love to hear all
that yeah well this is in the spirit of
this conversation is
that was back in 2015
that was there was starting to be a lot
of excitement of AI but there was also
starting to be this talk about
killer robot coming next door Terminator
is coming and I I was at that time
Andrew I was the director of slavery lab
and I was thinking
you know we know how far we are from
Terminators coming and that seemed to be
a really a little bit of far-fetched
concern but I was living my work life
with a real concern I felt no one was
talking about which was the lack of
representation in AI at that time I
guess after Daphne has left I was the
only woman faculty at Stanford AI lab
and and we're having very small around
15 percent of women graduate students
and we really don't see anybody from the
underrepresented minority groups in
Stanford AI program and this is a
national or even worldwide issue so it
wasn't just Stanford frankly it still
needs a lot of work today exactly so how
do we do this well I got together with
my former student Olga rosakovski and
also a a long-term educator of stem
topics Dr Rick Summer from Stanford
pre-collegiate study program and thought
about inviting high schoolers at that
time women High School young women to
participating a summer program to
inspire them to to learn Ai and and that
was how it started in 2015 and 2017 we
got
a lot of encouragement and support from
people like Jensen and Laurie Huang and
Melinda Gates and we formed the national
non-profit AI for all which is really
committed to training or or or helping
tomorrow's leaders shaping tomorrow's
leaders for AI from students of all
walks of life especially the
traditionally underserved and
underrepresented communities and
you know till today we've had many many
summer camps and summer programs across
the country more than
more than 15 universities are involved
and we have online curriculum to
encourage students as well as College
pathway programs to to continue support
these students career by matching them
with internships and mentors so it's a
it's a continued effort of encouraging
students of all walks of life yeah and I
remember back then I think your group
was printing these really cool t-shirts
that asked the question AI will change
the world who will change Ai and I
thought the answer of making sure
everyone can come in and participate
that was a great answer yeah still an
important question today yeah
so that's a great thought and I think
that takes us to at the end of the
interview
um any final thoughts for the people
watching this still that
um this is a very nascent field as you
said Andrew we are still in the middle
of this I I still feel there's just so
many questions that you know I wake up
excited to work on with my students in
the lab and I think there's a lot more
opportunities for for the young people
out there who want to learn and
contribute and shape tomorrow's AI
that's very inspiring
really great to chat with you and thank
you for thank you it's fun to have these
conversations